(cloche)
(chant religieux)
- Mon ange...
(Il baisse sa braguette.)
(aboiements)
(respiration haletante)
(en allemand)
- C'est qui, celui-là?
- Je sais pas.
Il va nous faire repérer.
(allemand, aboiements)
(sursaut)
- Je suis Jésus.
(coups)
(gémissements)
(grincement)
- C'est bon, ils sont partis.
- Aïe! Vous me faites mal!
- Évidemment
que je vous fais mal,
vous avez une balle
dans le ventre!
(toc-toc!)
Mon père!
- Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé?
- On a été trahis.
Allez, faut le soigner.
(gémissements)
(cri de jouissance)
(allemand)
- C'est le sérum?
- Oui, mission accomplie.
- Ouais. Un franc succès...
- Oh, ça va, vous.
C'est qui, celui-là?
- Pierrot, va te coucher!
C'est rien, c'est juste
mon séminariste.
- Il comprend notre langue,
votre gugusse?
(toc-toc!)
- Pierrot!
Emmène-les à l'église!
(toc-toc!)
- Ouvrez! Armée allemande!
- Allez!
J'arrive!
- Ouvrez!
- Oui, j'arrive!
(allemand)
Allez!
- Oui!
- Ouvrez!
(toc-toc!)
- Oui.
Oui?
Messieurs.
(porte, grincement)
(gémissements)
- On est à l'abri.
Ils nous chercheront pas ici.
Vous en faites pas, doc.
On va vous tirer de là.
- Je serais peut-être un peu
moins optimiste que vous.
(fracas)
Qu'est-ce que je vous disais?
- Putain, il est où, le sac?
- Y a un garçon qui l'a pris,
il est parti par là-bas.
- Oh!
(cris des Allemands)
(allemand)
Doc!
(cris en allemand)
(allemand)
- Hé! Rends-moi mon sac!
(cris de la fille)
- Vous savez
où ils nous emmènent?
- Sûrement au zoo.
Ensuite, si t'es sage,
ils t'achèteront une glace.
- Taisez-vous! Vous n'avez pas
le droit de parler!
- On comprend pas,
quand vous parlez,
avec les « ch » et--
- Silence!
- Ça va.
Là, j'ai compris.
- Et ça va,
la région vous plaît?
(respiration haletante)
- On a heurté quelque chose,
là, non?
(allemand)
- Rends-moi mon sac!
(cris)
- Là, c'est sûr,
on a heurté quelque chose.
(allemand)
- C'est qui, lui?
- C'est un résistant.
Il m'a sauvé la vie.
- Il faut le sortir de là.
Aidez-moi,
sa jambe est coincée!
Allez!
- La tôle est enfoncée,
on y arrivera jamais!
- Allez!
Hé! Tu fais quoi, là?
- Mais revenez nous aider!
- Laisse tomber,
il a pas de couilles!
- Poussez-vous de là,
je vais vous torcher ça.
(grincement)
Ah!
(gémissements)
- La bouteille...
(armement)
- Toi, là!
Fais quelque chose.
Tu peux pas l'aider?
Tire!
- Je vais pas tirer!
- Tire!
- Il a pas besoin de moi!
- T'as vraiment pas
de couilles!
- Il a pas besoin de moi!
- Tire!
Vas-y!
Mais qu'est-ce que t'as fait?
Qu'est-ce que t'as fait?
- Il saigne de partout!
- Quand on se coupe
avec une feuille de papier,
on saigne de partout aussi.
Ça veut pas forcément dire
qu'on va mourir.
- Vous entendez?
C'est les Allemands!
- C'était vraiment
un plaisir de vous rencontrer,
maintenant,
faut que j'y aille.
- Tu lui as tiré dessus,
t'es prêt à le laisser
à moitié mort?
- Il est pas à moitié mort.
- Tu nous aides
à le transporter maintenant!
- Faudrait vraiment partir
par contre! Allez!
- Allez!
- Bon. Poussez-vous.
Dégage! Allez!
Hé!
Tu crois qu'elle est folle?
Genre elle parle pas
notre langue
parce qu'elle a été élevée
par des loups.
Ça existe.
J'ai lu un bouquin là-dessus.
- En tant qu'homme d'Église,
je me permets de vous dire
que vous jugez les gens
un peu vite.
Je sais.
Je crois que tu es muette,
mais je connais un peu
le langage des signes!
- Je suis pas muette.
C'est juste que
quand j'ai rien à dire,
j'évite de parler.
- Je comprends, je suis pareil.
- Je m'appelle Pierre.
Et toi?
- Lorraine.
- Enchanté, Lorraine.
- Manu.
- Elle est pas muette.
- On a fait le maximum.
C'est fichu.
- Quoi? Il est mort?
- Non, mais presque.
Sa blessure va s'infecter.
On pourra pas le sauver,
il va nous ralentir.
Ça sert à rien de l'emmener.
- Quoi?
- Les loups lui ont appris
à avoir aucune compassion.
- En tant qu'homme d'Église,
je n'abandonnerai personne!
- Bon, bien, on l'abat, alors.
- Dans cinq minutes,
elle nous propose de le bouffer.
- Mais elle est folle!
T'as un vrai problème mental,
ma parole!
Qu'est-ce que tu fais
en liberté?
Il faudrait te mettre
dans un asile!
- Je trouve que tu juges
les gens un peu vite quand même.
- Je suis désolé.
Je le pensais pas!
- C'est bon!
J'ai trouvé un endroit
où on va pouvoir se reposer.
Elle est où, la folle?
(Il supplie en allemand.)
(efforts)
- J'ai le côté
avec le bras le plus lourd!
- Tu rigoles?
C'est moi qui porte tout.
- Bon. Arrêtez de vous plaindre.
On arrive.
(prière murmurée)
- Tu sais,
pour tout à l'heure...
Non, t'as l'air occupée.
Je veux pas te déranger.
- Quoi? Ça va, il fait moins 20.
Faut bien se réchauffer, non?
Quelqu'un en veut?
- Non, merci.
Je bois que du vin de messe.
- Non, merci. Ça ira.
- Comme vous voudrez.
C'est pas du vin!
On dirait du whisky avec...
avec du pneu.
Ça a un goût de pneu, en fait.
- Fais voir.
- Qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
de lui, maintenant?
- Le laisser se reposer
et se réchauffer un peu.
Puis on ira trouver
un village pour le soigner.
Quoi? Il nous a quand même
sauvés des Allemands, non?
- Moi, je suis de ton côté,
Solange.
Dieu est avec nous,
on doit aider notre prochain.
- Si on reste là, c'est pas
Dieu qui sera avec nous,
mais des dizaines de Boches.
- On va en zone libre.
Là, on sera en sécurité.
- Je suis d'accord
avec Solange.
Quand on est résistant--
- T'es résistante, toi?
Ça va, la guerre est terminée.
Les Allemands ont
aucune chance face à Mowgli,
l'enfant de la forêt.
- Tu fais quoi, toi,
contre les Allemands?
- « Tu fais quoi, toi,
contre les Allemands? »
Je fais rien.
Je les invite pas,
je les combats pas,
j'en ai rien à foutre.
- T'es un fuyard quoi.
- « T'es un fuyard, quoi. »
- Un fuyard
sans aucune répartie en plus.
- Putain...
- Non, merci.
J'en veux pas.
- Elle sait pas boire.
- Je t'ai pas attendu
pour boire. C'est juste
que là, j'ai pas envie.
- Peut-être préférez-vous
une pinte de schnaps,
madame « Je parle allemand »?
Alors, ça a un goût de pneu,
non?
- Ouais, j'avoue.
- Pour une fille
qui voulait pas boire,
tu manques quand même
pas mal de volonté.
(ronflements)
(soupir)
(sons bizarres)
(gazouillis)
- Oh, c'est toi! J'ai eu peur,
je croyais que c'était l'autre.
- Elle s'emmerde pas!
Puis toi non plus, mon salaud!
« En tant qu'homme d'Église »...
- Mais ça va, je suis
tombé dessus malencontreusement.
- Rends-moi mon calepin.
- Dis, la dévergondée,
va falloir arrêter
de dessiner ce genre de trucs.
T'es en train d'exciter le curé!
Allez hop!
Confisqué!
- Rends-moi mon carnet, Manu.
- Fais pas chier! Rends-lui!
- Tu veux pas le garder,
pour passer un bon petit moment?
- Là, faudrait peut-être
lui rendre, non?
- Non, je vais le garder.
D'ailleurs, c'est qui,
tes modèles?
Parce que je me disais
qu'on pourrait peut-être
boire un verre,
histoire de faire connaissance.
Je suis sûr que j'ai plein
de points communs avec elles.
Oh! Comment t'as fait ça?
- Je sais pas.
Je sais pas.
- Hé! Il s'est réveillé!
Bon, vous venez?
(gémissements)
- Ça va?
Vous allez mieux?
- La bouteille...
Qui a bu?
- Moi, je bois
que du vin de messe.
- Vous inquiétez pas,
on va vous amener au prochain
village pour vous soigner.
- Elle me fout les jetons.
Avec Manu, on l'a vue faire
une chose très étrange
avec un caillou.
Alors moi, j'ai ma théorie:
je pense qu'elle est possédée
par le malin.
- Il faut bien qu'on reste
en dehors des routes.
Y a des Allemands dans le coin.
- Y a une route juste devant.
- Parfait, on y va.
- Bien non.
Je viens de vous dire
que c'était dangereux.
- Il paraît que
vous êtes résistant.
- Donc on va vers la route,
c'est ça?
- Vous êtes communiste?
- Communiste? Bien, vas-y.
Vas-y, insulte-moi, toi,
pendant que tu y es!
- Ça va, on s'en fout
si c'est un bolchevique.
C'est toujours mieux
que d'être collabo.
Hein, madame
« Je parle allemand »?
- C'est pas parce qu'on parle
allemand qu'on est collabo!
- Gnagnagna! « C'est pas
parce qu'on parle allemand
qu'on est collabo!»
Quoi?
Ça va, j'ai juste répété
ce qu'elle a dit
en prenant une voix marrante,
je l'ai pas insultée non plus.
Qu'est-ce qui se passe?
Pourquoi on s'est arrêtés?
- Je sais pas
comment t'as fait ça,
mais recommence plus jamais!
(en choeur):
Sinon, t'es un homme mort!
- Quoi?
(en choeur): Tu te fous de
ma gueule! Arrête de m'imiter!
- Je contrôle plus mon corps.
(en choeur): Tu m'énerves!
- Aïe!
- Ah...
(gémissements)
- C'est le malin!
- Calmez-vous!
Je vais vous expliquer.
(aboiements)
- Ouais... Ça aurait été plus
rapide de le ramasser
directement.
- Et donc votre sérum,
vous l'avez caché
dans la bouteille?
- C'est ça.
- Il servait à quoi?
Y a quoi, dedans?
- Ça, je peux pas vous dire,
c'est classé secret défense.
- Je vois plus rien.
- Quand vous utilisez
vos aptitudes,
y a un petit effet secondaire.
- Mais c'est très chiant, ça.
On va tous devenir aveugles?
- Ça, je peux pas vous dire.
- C'est classé secret défense?
- Non, c'est juste
que j'en ai aucune idée.
- Et donc là,
vous me voyez en Pierrot?
- Ouais.
- Non.
- Wow!
- Je suis un peu mal à l'aise,
là...
- En tant qu'homme d'Église,
j'apprécie énormément les
dessins bizarres de Lorraine.
Des femmes à poil
et du vin de messe,
tel est mon paradis, Seigneur!
- Arrête ça!
- Qu'est-ce qui se passe?
Pourquoi vous me regardez
comme ça?
- Tu te souviens pas du tout
de ce que tu viens de faire?
- J'ai!
Quand tu deviens pas aveugle,
tu deviens amnésique.
Comme on a tous
une aptitude différente,
on a tous un effet
secondaire différent.
À toi.
- Pourquoi tu me regardes?
(gémissements)
- Arrête! Ah!
Arrête!
Ah!
Ah! Arrête!
- Bien apparemment,
mon effet secondaire,
c'est que je peux plus bouger.
- Ne peut plus bouger.
- Bien il est génial,
votre sérum.
Les Allemands ont du souci
à se faire.
Eh! Vous auriez pas un sérum
pour vous faire perdre
10 ou 15 kilos?
- Attention à ce que tu dis,
gamin.
Même blessé, je peux encore
te botter le cul.
(allemand)
- Des Chleuhs.
- On va dans le trou!
- Non, on se planque
derrière les arbres.
Dans le trou, c'est dangereux.
- Pas du tout!
On va...
(allemand)
- Ils arrivent!
- On fait quoi, alors?
On saute ou on se planque?
- On saute!
- On se planque!
(cris)
- Bon. On n'a plus
qu'à rester ici et...
(craquements)
- Eh bien, vous tombez bien,
parce qu'on cherchait
justement un bon coin à pêche.
- Avec un homme blessé
à terre?
- Eh... oui... Pierrot...
l'homme blessé à terre,
c'est qui?
C'est ton oncle?
C'est ton oncle, c'est ça?
C'est son oncle.
- Quoi?
- Ouais, bon, laissez tomber.
- Écartez-vous de cet homme
ou je tire!
- Comment osez-vous braquer
votre Führer?
Retournez à vos postes
ou je vous ferai exécuter!
(allemand)
- J'ai pas du tout l'apparence
d'Hitler, c'est ça?
- Non, pas du tout.
(allemand)
- J'y arrive pas. Il va le tuer.
Fais quelque chose!
- Je vais pas risquer ma vie
pour ce connard!
- Alors t'es de leur côté.
- Tu me traites aussi
de collabo--
- Si tu fais rien, ça fait
de toi une collabo, ouais.
(allemand)
- Ah!
(gémissements)
- Vise la tête.
- Voilà. Maintenant!
- Ah!
(allemand)
- Solange? Ça va?
- Oui.
(cris en allemand)
- Ils arrivent! Vite!
(gémissements)
- Bougez pas.
Qui êtes-vous?
- Oh, Lupin!
Ils sont avec moi!
- Bon.
Suivez-moi, vite!
- Faut aller chercher
les filles.
- Ah oui.
(coups de sifflet)
- Non!
- Allez, viens.
(aboiements)
- Ils sont juste derrière nous.
Accélère, Manu!
- Je fais ce que je peux.
- Allez!
Montez, vite!
(allemand)
(cloche)
- Bon. Et on fait quoi, nous,
maintenant?
- Vous avez bu un sérum
qui fait de vous des hommes
hors du commun.
Et des femmes aussi.
Aujourd'hui, vous êtes
notre meilleur atout
contre l'envahisseur,
vous êtes l'espoir
de la Résistance.
Je m'appelle Nemo.
Lui, c'est Lupin,
et voici Ravel.
Ensemble,
on va libérer la France.
Ensemble, on va mettre fin
à cette guerre
une bonne fois pour toutes.
Bienvenue
dans le réseau Hexagone.
- Et... si on veut pas être
résistant, on fait comment?
- J'osais pas trop le demander.
(conversations indistinctes)
- J'ai comme des visions.
- Quoi?
- Vous avez peut-être
des aptitudes.
Mais nous, on a ça!
Ce sont d'authentiques
faux papiers.
- Tu veux que je t'arrange
un coup avec la rouquine?
- T'es juif?
- Ça te pose un problème?
- À ton avis?
- Vous connaissez
l'opération Pont du diable?
- Comment tu connais?
- Il a fait un salut nazi
et s'est barré.
- Soit vous nous aidez
à contacter notre chef
pour vous faire passer
en zone libre,
soit vous partez.
À vos risques et périls.